a mass shooting this time in Thousand
Oaks California 12 dead including a
police officer
Ron Ellis who gave his life for others
here are his fellow officers paying
respects to their fallen brother on the
101
[Music]
now there is no shortage of ideas when
it comes to preventing such horror the
problem is the loudest voices only offer
two choices it's either you want more
gun control or you want to arm everyone
we need to escape this prison of two
ideas here's how one we need a system
that works we once had a process for
dealing with people who had a known
mental illness but the process is now
paralyzed by fear people don't want to
be pegged as violating someone else's
rights today psychiatric hospitals
housed less than 1/10 of the people they
did in the 1950s yet our population is
doubled
if we can't house them then at least tag
them so they can't get a gun the shooter
terrified his mom that's what we call a
red flag - we need an industry focused
on hardening soft targets a shooters
body count is limited by the time it
takes for a second weapon to arrive
enhanced security can only reduce that
time 3 finally the media must limit the
persuasive power of its coverage studies
of suicides verify the copycat
phenomenon with mass shooting the
spotlights no help religious and
political terror has an ideology
criminal homicide has a payoff it's
often revenge or profit this is the only
terror that exists as an end in itself
we can stop it but to do that we need to
open ourselves up to uncomfortable ideas
ones that take us out of our rigid teams
you know Danny when you look at you see
reoccurring red flags in these cases
that are just it's kind of infuriating
but you know that it's it is hard to
find a needle in a haystack but when the
needle you know when the mother is
terrified when the when the person has
been visited by experts because of
psychiatric problems you got to ask
yourself how can this happen and it's
you know the synagogue shooting that
shooter was a radicalized anti-semite
mm-hmm evil person was he mentally ill
as well I don't know yeah for this
individual the
deputies were called to the house
because the mothers of worry right the
deputies say you know what I think we
should call in following procedure
the psychic psychiatrist to come in to
do an evaluation they come they do this
evaluation they do it to the best of
their ability and at the end of it they
say our professional opinion is that he
is not a harm to himself or to others at
this time right and there's human error
that's going to be involved in this and
we also have the issue of Liberty yes so
how do we figure out how to how to deal
with this you're exactly right this is
the thorny problem we don't seem to ever
actually get past talking about it being
a throwing problem though yeah it's it's
the Jesse it is the okay if if people
say we need to do something about guns
then people go no more gun control and
if you say I think we need more
self-defense people say you just want
armed everybody with guns but there is a
place somewhere in the middle that can
solve this problem
yeah mr. [ __ ] remember meadows father
down in parkland he tweeted and it kind
of along the lines that you've been
talking about don't all of a sudden rush
to take everyone's guns away you have to
look at mental health you have to look
at security and you have to look at soft
targets because California is probably
one of the strictest gun control states
out there and the city third safest city
in California so if this could happen
there this could happen anywhere and if
you think about what Dana was just
saying if you had multiple police
contacts at the house neighbors that
were concerned law enforcement concerned
that he was terrorizing his mother
terrorizing himself possibly harming
himself one neighbor said and there was
thoughts of PTSD involved if you go and
send this guy to a mental health
professional and the mental health
professional then just checks this box
it's similar to what happened again in
the in the parkland shooter exactly this
guy you know he's off the charts insane
and they give him a clean bill of health
these mental health professionals I'm
not blaming them but they have to
address the modalities that they're
going through when they see is this
person a threat because they're letting
off a lot of people that then go out and
shoot people we have this guy he was a
machine gunner in Afghanistan I mean he
saw some nasty stuff yeah and has
probably done some nasty stuff so
you get a guy like this if he's really
seen a lot of action and he's already a
loner we knew that went through a
divorce living with his mom not a great
matrix there maybe there's a mandatory
mental health evaluation that you have
to do at the VA every single year if you
have a profile like this you go in they
check you out they address your mental
capacities and then maybe they can sign
off on something because right now
there's too many people slipping through
the cracks I just I just think there's a
the veterans community is concerned
about tagging people that have PTSD with
violence like this and for good reason
right because one we don't know there's
an exact link there could be mental
health problems from before and also
there's already stigma enough if you
have PTSD in terms of getting treatment
and so I it's not something we shouldn't
talk about I've gone away maybe you put
him in some sort of program where he can
talk about these issues yeah and maybe
get medicated or anything that could
help solve the problem I don't know can
I just point out though to your point
Jesse the gun laws in California are the
strictest and there are laws on the
books in California for this man's
family and any person's family to deal
with this and get a gun or guns out of
the hands of someone who is a threat to
themselves or other people there are
multiple ways to do that in the state of
California one if a person is taken into
custody evaluated by mental health
professionals and admitted to a county
mental health facility because that
person was found to be a danger to
themselves or others
it is generally prohibited from
possessing or acquiring firearms for
five years in California and then the
state of California was the first to
introduce gun violence restraining
orders four years ago to give a legal
path to family members and even law
enforcement officers to get a gun out of
somebody's hands and this is in the case
of potential suicide or violence to
others but there are mechanism in place
that in this case we're not used to I
dia that that was already in place yeah
so I just want to pick up on the top of
your monologue which was that we get
locked in a box and
terms of the conversations that we have
in this country because I thought that
was so important that people either say
oh no gun control or gun control right
and I just want to also point out as
Dana said this man had been interviewed
by healthcare professionals and found
not to be a threat to himself or others
so it's not the case that there hadn't
been attention and I would also say
think that it's very important to say
that people who have mental illness are
not of a greater proclivity to commit
gun violence there's no evidence between
gun violence and mental illness in this
country so to me what's important is
that we acknowledge we have too many
guns in this country and it makes for a
problem not only for gun violence but
for suicide in particular so I want to
say goodbye so I mean gun violence
against others the other thing that I
think is really important is that there
are points where we can agree as
Americans and I wish we would get to
that it's overwhelming if you ask
Americans about background checks
universal background checks Americans a
yes including gun owners NRA members say
yes that's a great idea let's do it
let's have a waiting period for people
who get guns did that stopped he got
this gun legally I'm sure there was no
background check no but in this case I'm
sure that was but remember he was
interviewed as Dana said by mental
health professionals who couldn't who
didn't have enough evidence in their
minds to say put this guy away or deny
him access and that's another thing that
if someone is found to be abusive of
their spouse or mom in this case right
they should not be allowed to have a gun
but I just deported agreement universal
background checks assault weapons and it
seems to me that you have to have a
sense that again how many guns can any
one person have in the country well he I
don't know how many my only takes one
yeah did you want to say no I just want
to say but families in that state in
many other states an increasing number
including Florida after the Parkland
shooting earlier this year if you have a
individual in your family who has a gun
or guns and you there's a path legally
to get that gun out of their hands if
you think that they're a violent threat
right okay and we just have to remember
every day the dangers that the police
and
or this is what they do this is what
they do for a living they rush towards
the bullet Dave he saved a lot of other
people yeah sergeant ron Heelys